[Music]
hello
and welcome to sophie ridge on sunday
more than half
of all adults in the uk have now
received their first
cover 19 vaccine dose a huge milestone
in the fight against the virus
but the very success of the program is
bringing its own
challenges conservative mps now calling
for freedoms to be restored as the
government prepares to ask
parliament to renew its emergency
coronavirus powers this week
and in europe grappling with its own
vaccine rollout and a potential third
wave of the virus
there's a threat to block astrazeneca
exports to countries with higher
vaccination rates
who could they be talking about lots to
discuss on the show today
well on this week's safer ridge on
sunday we've got a lineup to cover all
of that
and more we'll be speaking first to
steve baker the deputy chairman of the
coveted recovery group of mps
who wants to see restrictions eased the
defense secretary ben wallace
will be joining us live too and we'll be
putting your questions about the vaccine
i'm sure you've got lots of them to
professor jeremy brown who sits on the
uk's joint committee
on vaccination and immunisation shadow
health secretary jonathan ashworth will
be speaking to us about labour's call
for a coveted recovery plan
for the nhs and away from the pandemic
one of scotland's most senior judges
lady dorian will be telling us about her
proposals
to change the way the justice system
treats rape victims including a possible
end to jury trials
we'll also be asking the chair of
westminster's select committee on women
and equalities caroline knox
if the police and courts are biased
against women and
in what promises to be a huge week for
scottish politics
we'll be joined by the scottish health
secretary gene freeman
first though we can talk uh to the
conservative mp steve baker the deputy
chairman of the south styled coveted
recovery group thank you very much for
being on the program this morning
mr baker so this week boris johnson
is expected to be pushing through the
six months extension
of the coronavirus act which does things
like give the police more powers
how are you going to be voting and why
well i expect to vote against but
the thing is with so many vulnerable
people now vaccinated and record
progress being made people will be right
to ask why the government is still
seeking to hang on
to these powers to put it in context
under schedule 21
of the act there's been a 100 record of
unlawful prosecutions 246 people
unlawfully prosecuted the act makes
provision to for example postpone
elections
but we're not postponing elections this
year so the government does need to
answer why
as so many people are vaccinated then
not
relaxing restrictions in line with that
data so this easter for example
it will be unlawful to stay away from
home
and it will be unlawful to stay away
from home with another
household until the middle of may so
it we need to be really careful here
that the police don't end up in another
invidious position
where they're enforcing laws we've put
in place to the surprise of politicians
who they then seem to feign shock that
the public have been for example turn
around on our motorways and sent home
the big fine
um you're talking there about the
politicians failing shock about the
actions of the police i mean people
would also be thinking about the sarah
everard vigil
do you think the police should be taking
responsibility for
in some cases perhaps being too
heavy-handed or do you put blame at
the foot of politicians i think we
politicians have got to
take the blame here the police obviously
sometimes do make mistakes and there
have been instances which i wouldn't
defend like using drones
to pursue people um but and clearly it's
difficult to see how it was a wise
decision to break up
the vigil but that's not really the
point the point is the police are being
put in an invidious position
as the police federation have said as
dame cressida dick has said
we give them the law we expect them to
apply the law we expect them to apply
equally to all and we shouldn't be
surprised when they do so
so of course there are occasions when
the police unfortunately
perhaps go too far but you can't blame
them when we've passed
uh well rather we powers have been used
under 118 acts of parliament to cope
with coronavirus so it's an extremely
complex legal environment something
we've talked about before
on your show and the police have my
sympathy
and uh it's we politicians and the
government in particular of course
who control the business of the house of
commons who need to justify every power
they take and
every power that they seek to hold on to
particularly whilst they're also quite
rightly
boasting of the great progress we're
making on vaccinating people
you say that you're expecting to vote
against uh when this comes before the
house of commons next week how big
a rebellion do you think we could see
it's very difficult to say until we've
seen the exact
detail of what the government's uh
tabling and how the votes will come
but let's be absolutely clear because it
seems that labour and the snp
will vote for any old authoritarianism
these days it looks like the government
will of course
get their business with an enormous
majority but i do think it's important
that some of us do seek to hold
the government to account with these
extraordinary powers it's obviously a
very uncomfortable position for some of
us to be in when it's our own party and
that's why we're trying to do it in a
civilized way
asking reasonable questions but the
government will get its way
and at this stage i wouldn't like to say
how big any rebellion will be
of course the plan out of uh these
restrictions
is a path to freedom it's just it
unfortunately we believe many of us
believe that it squanders the advantages
of our great vaccination program so it's
difficult to see how
very many people will want to vote
against a path to freedom
but we'll need to look at exactly the
detail but the coronavirus act itself
i am expecting to vote squarely against
i think it's excessive and
disproportionate and the government
itself now isn't using its powers and
where the police gain powers in the act
as i've said it's a
100 unlawful prosecution rate so i think
the coronavirus act should now go
that would not put the furlough scheme
at risk we've double checked that and
had it confirmed by the house of commons
library
so obviously there's a lot to look at
this week but the government really does
need to start
taking advantage of their own great
success on the vaccination program
at the same time though lots of people
listening to you will be thinking the
one lesson of the last year
is that this virus is extremely
unpredictable
yes the vaccination program has been a
success so far but we are aware of
supply issues
bubbling up over the next month it is
unpredictable
they say that they want to lift
restrictions by june and get us back to
normal but again
we don't know when things like new
variants for example could rear their
heads is it not
sensible for the government in those
circumstances to
extend the act well it's sensible for
the government to take proportionate
powers
remember the civil contingencies act has
far greater provision for scrutiny by
parliament
when extraordinary powers are taken and
so one of the problems we've got here is
in our panic and in
in our sort of blindness to all other
factors we've ended up with the
government taking extraordinary powers
with very limited parliamentary scrutiny
and we would not normally have approved
such a thing
so really what i'm saying is to the
government they they really should now
start looking at
dramatically reducing the range of
powers that they have
making sure that the law is clear to the
public and that the government has taken
responsibility for that law so that the
police aren't in an invidious position
but yes of course this is a tricky
situation but
the chief medical officers have been
very clear with us that the
the vaccines are expected to still
protect people
from hospitalization and death even with
the variants you know that that is a
subject
over which we've gone many times we know
that most of the protection comes from
the first dose the second dose is about
longevity
that was a joint letter from the chief
medical officers so
people on my side of the argument are
trying very careful trying very hard to
carefully base
our arguments on what we're being told
by scientists
there's a bit of a live debate among mps
and among everyone really
about holidays about whether summer
holidays should be permitted to try and
open up the travel industry
or if actually because our vaccination
program may be
speeding along while others is a bit
more sluggish it would be more
sensible to press the pause button on
overseas travel
what's your position i think with
overseas travel there's a very good case
to
to look at it and say that actually
because of the situation in other
countries the government's got to take a
very careful view
but what an extraordinary situation it
isn't that you can't leave the country
freely i mean these are powers whatever
the government's decision whatever the
advice is these are powers which should
be taken
with great trepidation and regular
parliamentary scrutiny so i
do think in relation to international
travel i do think it's inevitable
with the situation where it is with
other countries vaccination programs
being
in such a different place i do think
it's inevitable that a different
approach will be taken to the one
domestically but i think we've got to be
sensible and proportionate on all sides
of this argument
but yeah i mean i do expect that if our
vaccination program is proceeding at
pace
and people are safe because they're
vaccinated then they should be able to
travel
but equally i hope you won't mind and i
think your viewers would expect me to
reserve my position a little to actually
look at the data
as it emerges uh yeah that's definitely
fair enough uh steve baker thank you
very much for being on the program uh
this morning always good to talk
you're very welcome thank you uh steve
baker they're making his position uh
pretty clear ahead of those
uh plans to extend the corona virus act
next week so let's
now find out uh what the position is
from the government we can go straight
to speak to the defense secretary ben
wallace
to get his reaction to the interview
with steve baker
mr baker says the plan to extend
coronavirus powers for another six
months
is authoritarian that there should be a
path to freedom instead
why do you want to extend it for that
amount of time
look we we have all of us whether you're
nhs workers or the members of public
made incredible sacrifices over the last
year
to make sure that we try and get on top
of this pandemic you know we are in a
place at the moment where
unlike many other countries we have
started to get on top of it
slowed the flow into hospitals started
to reduce the tragic loss
of life through it and started to roll
out the vaccine at an unprecedented
level
i don't think now is the time to throw
that away or potentially put that at
risk i think now is the time
to you know the final mile is the most
important thing for us all to make sure
that we
we buckle down get through the different
stages of the prime minister set out the
next one being the 29th of march and
then another one
on the 12th of april and slowly but
surely
all of us together make sure we tackle
this dreadful pandemic
i don't think anyone is saying that now
is the time
to lift restrictions or to stop the
powers but you're talking about
extending this
for another six months at a time when by
mid-april
the top nine priority groups should have
been vaccinated they accounted for 99
of deaths in the first wave restrictions
set to be lifted
uh towards the end of june why do you
need six more months
look parliament can put in place powers
and it can always remove powers if it
needs to i think
what we want to indicate and signal is
you know to the public at large
uh a plan that goes beyond a week by
week and a sort of long-term
plan and therefore that involves putting
certain tools in place
and none of us want to have lots of
draconian measures but
this is an unprecedented global pandemic
that has cost
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
of lives around the world
and therefore you know putting those in
place is really important
but of course you know as the prime
minister very very clear at each stage
we will be taking assessments from the
science from
where we are with this uh pandemic and
make the steps required
you know i i'm not going to second guess
what happens after june
i think that's that would be wrong and
you know my constituents
people forget this my constituents
president have been locked down
since the middle of august they have
sacrificed a huge amount
uh to deal with this pandemic and i
really think the first evidence foremost
thing to do
is to roll out the vaccines protect our
nhs and make sure we take it step by
step and
you know steve baker is a is a good
friend of mine he's a great
mp he's very diligent and i fully
respect his position and it's right
that the government has always asked
about powers that it seeks to take
and we listened to his contribution and
i listened to it just now
but you know for us as a government i
have to hold the balance
between the needs of my constituents to
be protected the needs of the nhs
and indeed the needs to get on top of
this virus so we can get the economy
back up and running
just to be clear uh you're saying that
politicians can impose powers but also
remove powers
you're saying that these powers may not
last the full six months you could take
them away earlier
well i think that's just going into the
realms of you know speculation i think
you said that you you were the one who
remains raised the idea of removing
the idea you know sophie you're saying
that you know
as if it's a one-way street i think you
were trying to imply that just because
we're going to put
powers in place and somehow that is
means it will definitely definitely be
there
for a very long time i think the point
is we're going to put the
powers in place to deal with the
pandemic and the measures that we think
need need to be implemented and uh
complied
but they could be put in they could be
extended safely
all these things are what parliament can
do parliament is there to obviously
scrutinize government proposals
i think my point is it is not a one-way
street just because we are seeking to
have the powers
it doesn't mean to say we're deaf to you
know how facts change on the ground and
all the way through this following the
science following the facts
you know looking at outbreaks around the
world has informed us it'll inform us
with the task force around international
travel that's going to report to the
prime minister of april
it'll inform us around the passporting
task force and
also inform the prime minister in april
and we will take it step by step but you
know for my constituents who have been
locked down you know since
august having a sense of of plan
having a sense of stability is probably
the most important things that they can
get on with their lives get their
children back to school but also
understand
you know what the government's next
steps are you mentioned
how the plans will inform things like
foreign travel what is the position on
foreign travel is it likely that we'll
be able to go
on holiday this summer and what are your
own holiday plans
well my colleague the defense at the
transport secretary said
only recently that it's highly unlikely
we'll be able to go on foreign holidays
as such
uh you know this side of may or indeed
in early may but
you know we're going to wait for these
task force to report uh to the prime
minister in april they're going to take
a look at it
you know we can't be deaf and blind to
what's going on outside the united
kingdom if you look in europe
the increases of infections and we can't
put at risk
the huge amount of effort by the
taxpayer by the nhs
by our scientist in developing this
vaccine and if we were to
uh be reckless in any way and import new
variants that put that put at risk then
you know what would people say about
that
this you know we we've got a good
direction of travel we're getting there
and i think we need to make sure we
preserve that at all costs
you mentioned there the rising cases in
europe there's also been a lot of
criticism of the vaccine rollout
across the eu as well and ursula von de
lyon with the backing of
france and germany has again threatened
to potentially block
exports of astrazeneca uh to countries
such as the uk who've got a higher
vaccination rate than
many uh in europe now the foreign
secretary has accused you eu of acting
like a
less democratic countries do you think
that the eu is
acting like a dictatorship
well look i i will take uh president of
the european commission's words that she
gave to the prime minister a few months
ago that you know
europe the european commission and and
britain were not going to engage in
breaking contracts now all of us
recognize the importance of
international law and upholding contract
law around the world
i mean the european union will know that
the rest of the world is looking at the
commission
about how it conducts itself on this and
if if contracts get broken and
undertaken
you know that that is a very damaging uh
thing to happen for a trading block that
prides itself on the rule of law prides
itself on
following you know contracts with an
open trading block
and i think you know the commission
knows deep down the world is watching
what happens
and also be counterproductive because
the one thing we know about vaccine
production and manufacturers
is it is collaborative you know the in
oxford
university and astrazeneca invented
developed this uh the intellectual
property
that led to the vaccine how the vaccine
is manufactured involves countries
not just in europe not just in the
united kingdom but even further afield
in such places as
india and if we start to unpick that and
if the commission were to start to do
that
i think they would undermine not only
their own citizens
chances of having a proper vaccine
program but also many other countries
around the world
with a reputational damage for the eu
that i think they would find
very hard to change over the short term
it's interesting that you talk about the
interdependency of vaccine manufacturing
that's something that pfizer has
reportedly
also flagged to brussels and the eu
saying that actually
parts of the ingredients that they need
are made in the uk
if the eu did decide to block exports do
you think you could see
some kind of retaliation from countries
like the uk
look so first of all the united kingdom
already has its own manufacturing
capability in some areas and you know
because of the decisions the government
took and matt hancock and the prime
minister
earlier on you know we have invested in
a range of
of types of vaccines that will give us
more opportunities we'll continue to
explore
growing those supplies if needs be but
you know i i think
you know let's remember we have now
vaccinated over half the adult
population
unprecedented levels for a country of
our size
well above most countries or all
countries in europe
and we're on the right direction we're
going to continue to vaccine i myself
got my first text the other day calling
me
to have my vaccination and you know day
by day that the vaccines minister
and man hancock will explore all supply
routes
and i think you know the commission
knows deep down the governments of the
european union know deep down
that you know this would be
counterproductive uh to start uh
effectively uh down this down this route
of uh
if if it is true what she's been saying
and i think that's what we've heard
i think they're under tremendous
political pressure of the european
commission
i think it's really a matter for them of
how they deal with it but you know the
values
that they espouse of the european union
of upholding the rule of law
being a trading bloc all of that means
that you follow those contracts that you
you honor them that you agreed
and i think you know it would damage the
eu's reputation globally
should they renege on those things okay
now
congratulations by the way on getting
your own vaccination text
we know of course we've had an
absolutely stonking couple of days for
the vaccine roll out but things could
get a bit more bumpy
over the next month partly because of
this delay
from india can you just explain
what is the reason for that delay the
prime minister said that india hasn't
blocked anything we've been told
technical reasons but frankly i mean
that is
quite meaningless the idea of just
technical reasons
why has that been delayed and as a
result
of these issues in the supply chain are
we now looking at trying to manufacture
more doses here in the uk
well first of all as i said earlier so
if we already have a manufacturing
capability
in the united kingdom we're always
exploring uh where we can increase that
manufacturing capability whether that's
home or with other
international partners will continue to
do so i'm afraid i don't know the exact
details of of what's going on in indian
factories and development but
you know what we have seen you know we
saw it with uh i think astraze and
pfizer is that
these technical issues are real they do
happen when you suddenly massively
expand
a vaccination program what what you get
at the end of that is you know sometimes
you know that that takes time you would
have reported a few weeks ago the
slowdown in supply
which i think upset european commission
at that stage when some of the factories
in europe had to reset
and enlarge i think that's perfectly to
be expected
and that's why uh the prime minister
appointed nadimas arway as
a vaccine minister to make sure we did
everything we can globally to iron out
supply chains
um talking as well just finally on the
vaccine we've seen
a difficult week for astrazeneca uh
european countries
pausing the rollout many of them
restarting it and of course this comes
off the back of
for example the french president
describing it as quasi-effective
do you think some of this criticism of
the astrazeneca
vaccine is political rather than being
based on science
well i think what it shows and you know
as defence secretary uh
sort of here to hopefully launch our
defense reforms
uh what it shows is that in the world we
live in the global world we live in
information is a very very important
tool and we have to make sure that
as politicians and as governments of
country we are responsible
with how we use that information and
that we are how's the french president
been responsible
i'll let the media be a judge of that my
view is that the
european medical agency has approved
astrazeneca to be safe
a number of countries that said they
were going to pause it have now done a
uter
and are starting to roll it out i think
it's really for the governments of each
of those european countries
to answer the questions of their own
citizens about why or when they're going
to get their vaccines
okay now as you say you are defense
secretary you're publishing the defense
command paper
tomorrow now there are reports the army
is going to be cut
by 10 000 troops as part of that is that
true
well i'm not going to reveal on on the
media before parliament i'm afraid the
details
of numbers of our men and women other
armed forces you know
it's important that i deliver the
command paper parliament establishes the
armed forces
and that is my obligation to parliament
so i'm not going to
get into the speculation we had in
november a speculative story i remember
in the bbc about cutting the army to 65
000. i've seen lots of numbers used
i think the assurance i can give the
viewers is that you know what i will be
doing is making sure we have an armed
forces it's the right size
to meet the threat and the right size to
meet the government's ambition
of having a global britain that can
uphold values and support its allies
and you're launching this new spy ship
what's the idea
well i think back in november the prime
minister announced a a multi-role
surveillance vessel i don't call it a
spy ship i mean obviously what's key
here is to make sure that we
protect our critical lash infrastructure
what we what we have seen is that our
adversaries have spotted
that some of our weaknesses are
obviously different from what they were
10 20 years ago
we are very very dependent on things
like cables and satellites in space
and if we don't invest in the
capabilities to protect those
then we will be left deeply vulnerable
and there's lots of media reporting
around
some russian programs that we have seen
about looking at that
and therefore it's my duty as defense
centrally to make sure we invest in
capabilities to make sure the lights
don't go out at home
are you talking a lot of course about a
sort of changing world and sort of new
threats one of the biggest challenges of
course
is how to deal with china now
this week your integrated defence review
called for a positive trade and
investment relationship with china
in light of china's actions in hong kong
towards the uyghur muslims
shouldn't we be a bit tougher than that
well i think we have we are certainly
tougher than previous governments we are
putting in place new legislation to make
sure that's not hard when you look at
david cameron and george osborne
sophie look what i would say is we are
you know putting in place
laws to make sure that we the government
can protect
our security and our businesses from
necessarily from being bought up
potentially by chinese companies
that would seek to take away that
intellectual property the
foreign secretary a few weeks ago set
out a range of measures
to look at companies that may trade when
in the region of china where the uygha
are being systematically and clearly
persecuted and we have over the time
called out
uh members of the chinese government
who've been involved in cyber crime and
cyber espionage you know and not only
that we've also raised it in the u.n and
asked for
uh you know investigations and further
work on
uh calling out this behavior they're
calling out though just to come in
sorry just to come in because some
people listening to you will say calling
out that's just not enough is it just
calling somebody out china's not going
to care about that you want to have a
positive trade and investment
relationship this is a country that's
holding weakest in camps that there are
reports of women being forcibly
sterilized children being taken away
and left in orphanages is the position
effectively that if you're
wealthy enough for country if you're an
important enough trading partner then we
won't do anything else other than just
say a few words that calling you out
no sophie look first of all we live in
the world we live in not in the world we
necessarily
are at or wish to be and on that route
to get there what we need to make sure
is that we use all
the tools we have at our disposal but
you know british companies up and down
this country
trade with china their customers go into
shops and buy things
from products that are manufactured in
china and yes we want to do more to
encourage
british manufacturing and more to
diversify that supply chain because that
is ultimately the best way
to get stronger leverage on china to get
their behavior to change which is
to be a less dependent on them but also
use those levers and i think
my point of view would be if we didn't
trade with china we would actually have
in some areas less levers to try and
influence china's behavior
you know the international community
alongside the united states
and others and in the u.n know that if
we want
china's behavior to change we think it
is appalling what's going on in the uk
but you know we cannot just overnight
stop uh trading directly with china what
we can do is take steps to make sure
that
the trade we do is restricted that the
trade
you know we we have an arms embargo on
china for example
and that we take steps we are wide-eyed
about
china's place in the world but china's
place in the world is significantly
uh large and and you know again as i
said you know
over the years people have had a
different relationship with china we are
effectively resetting that making it
very clear the parameters
and taking steps where we can okay
um ethiopia a huge issue
at the moment a really devastating
situation four months of war half a
million people
lost their homes what is the uk doing
well first of all the united nations
we've called that out
led calling out of that we've also the
ambassador asked
and called upon the forces there to
de-escalate
and we're horrified by what we've seen i
think we're going to investigate that
further
and the ambassador on the ground has
been very clear we call upon all the
parties
uh to step away and you know it's just
it's just horrendous what's been going
on and
and that's why you know at the un and
obviously we are chairing the security
council at the moment in the united
nations making sure
uh that the united nations and the
international community come up come
along
to make sure that this just doesn't get
any worse and in fact we deal with those
people
that have done those things and one more
very quick question while i have you uh
reports today that refugees are going to
be granted
indefinitely to remain in the uk to try
and encourage
more legal routes uh what's the idea
well i the will obviously announce the
details next week when the bill is
launched at parliament uh and i don't
think i would uh speculate on on some of
the press reports about
uh legislation before it is put forward
or indeed white papers to govern but i
think
i think first and foremost we recognize
that the asylum seeker
is not working well we have to deal with
that we have to also deal with the
people traffickers that
bring people across the channel they are
wicked people uh doing some horrendous
things
and you know it is not in a place we
want it to be and and so we've got to
work with it we also recognize however
that you know conflict drives a lot of
this migration which is why
you know as defense secretary i have to
you know make it very clear to people
that
defense is not only in the business if
it has to of hard power such
as you know fighting a war if that's
what is required to defend this nation
but also in the business of conflict
prevention and you talk about the issues
around
for example ethiopia you know we are in
sudan we're in somalia
over the years as the british armed
forces because security is often
first and foremost what is most
important to preventing
those refugee flows in the first place
okay
thank you so much for being on the
program today ben wallace there thank
you
that was the defense secretary now as we
were just discussing it's been a big
week for vaccinations in every sense
on friday a record number more than 700
000 people got the jab
but issues with supply means the uk
won't keep up that place and despite
all the evidence europe's stop-start
attitude towards astrazeneca
may have raised concerns in some
people's minds about safety
now we've been asking you to send in
your questions we've got just the man to
answer them professor jeremy brown sits
on the uk's joint committee
on vaccination and immunisation thank
you very much for
being with us today and before we get to
viewers questions i've just got a couple
from
myself if you wouldn't mind um half of
uk adults
have now received their first dose of a
vaccine a
huge milestone of course but there are
issues with supply over the next month
how
concerned should we be about those
issues and do you think they will
definitely be resolved after four weeks
uh the truth i said good morning
stephanie is is i don't really
know because the supply side of things
is not really what the jcbi is involved
with
i mean it does look like we are i mean
we have been making a vaccine
program which is doing almost five
million a week which would have been a
fantastic
uh result if we could maintain that but
it's always been supply a vaccine that
has been the concern that might delay
things and
and yes i suspect our vaccine program
will be delayed slightly compared to
where
we thought it might have been a few
weeks ago but then at that point we're
actually ahead of schedules so we're
probably going to fall back to
the the original schedule and end up
with everyone who's an adult being
offered your vaccine by
towards the middle to end of the summer
okay
yeah not too long to wait then for all
adults certainly
um now as you say we've been making some
great progress we're going to vaccinated
all the top nine priority groups
and by mid-april they account for 99
of deaths in the first wave at the
beginning of the program we heard from
steve baker who was saying that because
of the success of the vaccination
program
we should now look at lifting some of
the restrictions and
what's your take on that okay this is
this is a a slightly complicated and
tricky thing to describe
but at the moment we have roughly
sort of 1995 of people who have been
who are high risk being vaccinated but
that
five or ten percent of people is still a
significant number and also
we've mainly done one dose of vaccine
which gives most of the protection
but not all of the protection until
we've done the second dose in
everybody's been vaccinated
there is a little degree of infection
that still occur
so if you completely lift all
restrictions there will be
a wave of infections crossing the
country and those that are not protected
either because the first vaccine hasn't
worked very well in them and they need
their second dose
or because they have not had a vaccine
at this point in time but are still
vulnerable
they will get infections and they will
probably end up in hospital
and diet so if you lift restrictions
there this even though most people are
at risk of being vaccinated the
proportion that
not still represents a very large number
of people who could end up
with serious infection that's a very
clear explanation thank you
and there has of course been some people
who are slightly hesitant about getting
a vaccine a bit worried and of course
what we've seen
in europe with the astrazeneca vaccine
may not have helped things and just take
france
as an example first they only allowed
that jab for the under 65s then it was
suspended then the suspension was lifted
now it's only allowed for over 55s the
president described it as
quasi-effective of course
and then the prime minister took it and
do you think some of this is more about
politics and science
okay so that's a i can't i can't answer
for the politicians and why they're
making certain statements
but i don't think the vaccine committees
in the different countries are making
their decisions because of politics
but i do think they've been misguided in
the way they've approached this where
they felt the precautionary principle
was that
because of the issue raised about blood
clots they should stop the vaccination
program the astrazeneca until they
looked into it whereas in fact
actually if you looked at the data it
was unlikely to be a serious issue
in the first place and the benefit of
the vaccine
far outweighs any potential risk due to
blood clots etc so i mean
the numbers are like you know one
hundred thousand fold more likely
that you would die of covid and that the
vaccine prevent that
then anything could possibly happen with
the blood clots
so i think stopping and starting the
program
was a uh a strategic error by the other
countries and could it left to more
deaths
well yes literally i mean i think it's a
bit complicated because again
you stop the vaccine program for a few
days what that means is that
the the vaccine program is pushed back
by a few days and perhaps maybe the
scheme of things that's not a great
uh a great loss but actually
at this point in time they are having a
third wave of infections so
actually it does represent a delay in
the vaccine program
just when they need it the most so i do
think that was
not well thought out okay let's um bring
in some questions from viewers we've had
a great response actually and this one
from jeanette on instagram
she asks i got the fires of jab first
time well i definitely get it from the
second jab because i'm reading there may
be a shortage of findo
in the next few months yeah as far as i
understand yeah i'm not
an expert on supply but the everyone who
said the fires of the first time would
get the flights of the second time and
the an astrazeneca
ditto the same they get ashamed for the
second time and the supply has been
matched
to allow that to happen so that should
happen reassuring news there for
jeanette and this is a question we've
got through twitter uh once we've
vaccinated the top nine cohorts in the
uk
and we have enough supply for second
doses doesn't it make sense to assist
the rest of europe where deaths and
hospitalizations are rising
yeah this one i i struggle with this a
little bit i have to say
i mean there's a certain amount of i
like to get the whole country sorted as
quickly as possible
but the issue about vaccinating the rest
of the world there's an ethical and also
a self-interest
in doing so i i suppose the question is
what can we do to help
the europeans with their vaccine program
and i don't actually think that the uk
can help that much because supply isn't
necessarily the problem anymore in
europe
and it's the sort of the rollout how you
deliver it
how you convince the local population to
take it which is the problems
and those really are local questions for
the european countries themselves
i think it's a different question for
the developing world where
delivering the vaccines in the
development is going to be an immense
task and very complex and
i do believe the uk should uh contribute
to that in a big way as much as it can
okay and this is a question from joe
edwards we've got a lot of similar
questions to this actually
um she asks what is the plan for
immunosuppressed people
i've had both doses of the vaccine but i
haven't developed any antibodies what's
the plan
okay so this is quite close to my heart
because my clinical practices i look
after people i've got lung problems
who with leukemia or bone marrow
transplants and the infection in that in
that population is a big issue due to
their weak immune systems
so the first thing i can say i can be a
little bit reassuring is that
uh the question i've seen in the in the
email is that
actually she's not developed antibodies
to the vaccine the question
that actually may not reflect that she
has no immune system
response to the vaccine because there
are multiple levels to the immune
response to the vaccine
the antibody that the nhs measures is
the n antigen and you would not get an
antibody response to that
if you've been vaccinated because it
doesn't the vaccine doesn't contain the
anatomy it contains the
spike yes antigen
i'm sorry great answer to that question
uh definitely um
will be a bit of reassurance there i
think for joe um
simon usher posted this question on
instagram
how long will the covert vaccine last
before having to receive
additional doses in the future yeah
the simple answer is i don't know and
nobody knows because we've not had long
enough to see i mean what we need to
know is what the antiquated response
looks like 12 months after vaccination
and as the
clinical trials were published from the
then of december last year we're going
to have to wait until
autumn before we can actually answer
that question with any degree of
confidence uh and just final
a final question here this is from
twitter's from kieran
um he asks what's the point of vaccines
if once
everyone eligible has had the jab we're
still expected to follow mask on social
distancing rules
i don't expect this to be asked because
it rocks the bait which of course makes
me really want to ask this question
and so what is what is the point of
vaccines yeah
i think i answered that question a
little bit earlier i mean i think
essentially until we can suppress
infection going around the country which
means vaccinating everybody
then some degree of social distancing or
protection is going to be required just
because
even a small proportion of people who
have not been vaccinated
or where the vaccine has not worked very
well will be a high risk of disease
if we have no control control infection
and the control of the infection comes
in once
a very high proportion of the country
being vaccinated we now know that the
vaccine does prevent transmission of the
degree
but that only works on a population
level once you've
vaccinated a high proportion of the
population so that's that's phase two of
the vaccine program
some really fascinating answers there
i'm sure that and the viewers will be
really happy with those responses uh
just one final one from me if i may
before we let you go
um just to clarify um are you expecting
every adult in the uk to have received
first dose by the end of july or do you
think that could now slip into
august i don't know i think july august
city
those are the ballpark areas where where
we would hope
that every adult has been offered their
first dose of the vaccine
okay that and that is very helpful thank
you so much for being on the program
thank you for asking our
questions as well much appreciated all
right
now the pandemic has of course put a
huge strain on the nhs and resources
prioritized to tackle people dying from
covert
but that of course means that waiting
lists for other kinds of treatment have
grown from cancer care to mental health
so let's talk about this with the shadow
house secretary jonathan
ashworth who joins us from leicester and
by prioritizing covet have we taken our
off the ball when it comes to
other important health conditions
well it's understandable as to why we
had to prioritize
covid because to be frank if you under
fund your nhs
over many years if you cut beds if you
try and run your nhs with
vacancies for a hundred thousand staff
and you cut
training you cut public health you cut
social care
that means when a crisis like this hits
you're more exposed and vulnerable
but we shouldn't have to make a choice
between covered care
and cancer care but that's what we've
been doing and today
we're missing all the targets or the
main targets for cancer care
we've got a huge backlog in our waiting
list over 300
000 people now waiting beyond 12 months
for treatment
it was 1600 a year ago this is risking
loss of livelihoods and permanent
disability for some it's risking
loss of life so we're saying to the
government we need an nhs
rescue package we need a plan to put the
funding into the nhs
but crucially we need a plan now to
recruit the staff
that we're going to need for the future
to deliver the quality care that
patients deserve
um now we've been talking a lot about um
covid
and of course the coronavis act later on
this week that everyone's gonna be
voting on steve baker uh earlier
on the program said that labour would
vote for any old authoritarian measures
so he expects you to
vote in favor of extending the app for
another six months
um is he right
i don't i don't agree with the way he's
characterized it and of course he voted
and lots of conservative mps voted for
lots of photo authoritarian measures
last week
in the house of commons that whether we
like it or not
the virus is still circulating we have
we're having we've got around 6000
infections
a day that is a high level of virus
circulating
it's much less than where we have been
obviously but it's still
quite dangerous out there so yes
vaccination is rolling
ahead and is is succeeding but we still
have to be cautious
we still have to proceed carefully we
have to be driven by the data
and that will mean i'm afraid that
governments will have to have
the powers to impose restrictions where
necessary
so there are bits of that act which need
to be properly
scrutinized and haven't actually been
implemented and i'm going to be asking
matt hancock
why certain elements of that act around
social care
continuing health care needs to remain
on the statute book
but there's other elements in that act
which i believe are needed
governments do need to be able to impose
restrictions governments do need to pay
statutory sick pay from day one i'd
actually like them to go further and pay
more sick pay
and governments do need to stop people
being evicted from their homes
if they can't pay the rent because of
the because of their livelihoods
have been uh so hit by this pandemic so
you'll be very next piece of language
in favor though it's a complex piece of
legislation
we will we broadly support it it ought
to be properly scrutinized
i mean i think what is frustrating is
that steve baker who i think will have
tremendous respect for
should be given the opportunity to put
forward amendments to the act
but the way in which the government
timetable these these uh
deliberations means he's denied that
opportunity
this act okay it was emergency
legislation a year ago it should be
properly scrutinized now
and if steve baker and graham brady
wants to work with us
to get the house of commons to agree a
proper process
to to thoroughly scrutinize our act so
we can all put forward amendments
i'd be happy to sit down with him
tomorrow to see if we can find that
procedure
um you're clearly concerned about um the
way ahead
you say that we shouldn't take our foot
off the the pedal if you like
um and there are rising cases in europe
as well what is your position on
summer holidays are they something that
needs to be sacrificed
in order to keep cases low here
well i've always said we have to proceed
with caution
we have to study the data at every stage
because sadly and i don't want to
be to disappoint the viewers but just
vaccination in the whole of the united
kingdom while important
and will save lives does not make us
bulletproof
it does not make us completely safe we
are only safe
when everybody is safe so so long as the
virus appears to be surging in france in
germany and parts of europe
which it is at the moment because this
is their this is their b117 wave
that's the kent variant that we've had
our kent variant wave
if you like their kent variant wave is
now
surging so we are not safe while the
virus circulates in these huge numbers
across the world
and of course we run the risk that more
variants more mutations emerge
which bounce back and hit us and
potentially evade the vaccine success
that we have had
so that it's a long long way to answer
your question is that
it's too early to make a judgment around
the may 17th
date on international travel i would
argue
i'm not expecting myself to go on a on a
a holiday abroad this summer but we'll
obviously
keep these things under review and we
have to continue to do all we can
to squash the infections down and
protect the successful vaccination here
in the united kingdom
well after speaking to you and ben
wallace this morning it does feel like
maybe
holding back on booking that foreign
holiday might be a good move
just finally while i have you labor have
selected
uh the former mp paul williams to fight
the hartlepool
by-election uh he was on an all-male
all-white shortlist of one
in the labour party is everyone a
feminist until he doesn't seek
as long as it suits you and then stops
well we're still committed to all
women's short shortlists and improving
the representation
uh of women in parliament we've actually
got more than 50 i think
of women in the parliamentary labor
party because of because of all women
shortlists and we're very proud of that
and we will continue to use
all women shortlists in in parliamentary
selections
uh and and future by-election selections
just not this one
well i wasn't involved with this i mean
i'm not i'm not on the label of any c
who takes these decisions i'm pretty
busy
dealing with our covered response to be
honest but we will you we will use all
women shortlists
in other parliamentary selections i've
got absolutely no doubt of that okay
jonathan ashworth thank you very much
for being on the program this morning
thank you
now away from the pandemic a review
group led by one of scotland's most
senior judges has recommended that a new
specialist call
should be created to deal with serious
sexual offences now the recommendation
recommendations from lord justice clark
lady dorian
aimed at making the experience for
victims less traumatic
now the report recommends the use of
pre-recorded evidence so that victims
don't need to keep repeating traumatic
stories a new
specialist court will be set up so
judges prosecutors and defenders will
get training
to deal with vulnerable witnesses and
the most dramatic suggestion
was a pilot where cases would be heard
only by a
judge with no jury now i ask eddie
dorian to explain more about her report
and the reasoning behind it
the main recommendation is for a
specialist
court to deal with all serious cases
of sexual assault or any other sexual
offences
and that that court should be staffed
by individuals who have had a particular
training trauma informed training
from the judges all the way down through
all the participants and that there
should be in addition to that as a
default feature of the court that the
evidence of
complainers in sexual cases should be
captured
on video in advance of the trial well in
advance of the trial
one of the most eye-catching someone say
controversial
uh things to that you put forward as a
suggestion is that some trials could be
done
not by juries but by judges what is the
thinking behind that do you
basically not trust juries to always
give the right verdict
in some of these very sensitive cases
the the
reasoning behind that was that we are
dealing with in this review we're
dealing with the problem
about how these cases are managed that
has been with us for many many years
and we keep having similar discussions
about them
and in the course of our discussions we
looked at other options for
dealing with these cases other than
juries and considered that this was a
subject that needed to be
examined further so we're not
recommending that juries should be
abolished for these cases
we're simply saying that's a
conversation that needs to take place
and needs to be informed by
public discussion and is that because
you are worried that
rape myths or preconceptions i guess are
quite widespread among society
it's because we feel that the
idea that we simply carry on doing
things the way that we have always been
doing them isn't necessarily the best
way forward
and if we're exploring the idea of a
completely new court we should be
open to looking at all other options
that could be available
it's interesting to hear one of the
judges who's been quoted to say that in
some of these
sensitive cases where there's evidence
of equality and quantity which for any
other kind of crime
would lead to a conviction i see a
number of acquittals each year in rape
cases which to my mind
are not explicable by rational
application of the law to the evidence
is that something that you agree with
that's one of the
uh discussion points that uh
featured in the course of the debate
about the
various options that were available and
was the view put forward
in the course of debate which informed
our eventual conclusion
um do you think the current setup is
perhaps biased against women in
any way what we felt was that the
current system required to be
improved so that the complainers men and
women
uh found that the experience was uh was
less
traumatic yeah it's interesting we you
talk about the idea of it being
traumatic the idea of going through the
whole process of reporting
you know violent crime or or a rape
against yourself
one of the former chief constables of
nottinghamshire police told women's hour
this week
that she would hesitate before bringing
anything forward and
she would struggle she said to report a
crime against herself
because of what she described as the
endless repeated humiliation
i mean do you feel that too well one of
the factors that we
felt was necessary for us to look at
was whether there were aspects of the
way things are dealt with at the moment
which um did not assist complainers
to move on from having the experience
that they'd had
and which were capable of
re-traumatization
one of the most common issues that arose
in that discussion was that
people felt having to tell their give
their account
repeatedly was something which
was capable of re-traumatizing them and
so
we looked at whether we could start from
a position
that a court would adopt
trauma-centered trauma-based
approaches uh which would uh avoid that
and we've seen such an outpouring of you
know grief and anger after the
sarah everard's um death um in the uk
um do you feel that now is the time to
really start seriously looking
in scotland but also in other parts of
the uk as well about how we deal with
these
crimes against women girls well
obviously
cases of of murder would not be
part of the remit of our
review we were dealing only with sexual
offences
but one of the things that drove the
review was
the feeling that it was necessary to
look at
how these cases as a whole were managed
and that we could do better and if you
look at the conviction rates for rape
and also sexual offences
they've always been pretty low and it
feels like they're getting worse i mean
certainly
in england and wales over the last three
years rape convictions more than
halved do you think things are getting
worse
well we didn't proceed on the basis that
the conviction rate was a driving factor
in our report we proceeded
on the basis that what was necessary was
to find a better way of managing the
cases that
avoided traumatization we very
specifically
decided that we should not approach
matters on the basis that was any kind
of
appropriate conviction rate
or that convictions should be a marker
of success
so we adopted a completely different
approach which was simply to look
at the experience of those who
were complaining of sexual violence
women or men it has it been quite hard
in your career to
have seen the impact on some of these
people who do come forward
yes some of the accounts that we had
that explained that people felt
re-traumatized after their
engagement with the criminal justice
system
was one that was difficult for us to to
to hear because
uh clearly that is not the intention
and we had to listen to that and find
a way of creating a system that would
not do that do you feel that rape has
been
effectively decriminalized in the uk
because of the low conviction rates
uh i don't think that's something that
was within review
groups remit or that i can comment on
it's a crime that's taken very seriously
and it continues to be taken very
seriously and
this review shows how seriously we
intend to take it
okay thank you so much and thank you so
much for coming on and explaining some
of the details about the review as well
lady dorian there well let's get some
reaction to that interview and the
review
we're joined now by caroline noakes the
chair of the women and equalities
committee at westminster thank you for
being with us
um we just heard there some of the
details of lady dorian's review into
making the
whole justice system easier for victims
of rape and serious sexual offences
would you like to see some of these
changes apply
throughout the uk well i think it's
important to reflect that scotland has a
separate
justice system but it's absolutely
crucial that we find
effective ways to support victims
through the criminal justice
system whether they be male or female
and
there have been good initiatives put in
place the independent sexual violence
advisors who are supporting complainants
through the whole process and being with
them
in court but i think there are some
really significant problems
about encouraging victims to come
forward making sure that police make
referrals to the cps
making sure that the cps has the
confidence to take things to trial that
we see
not just more convictions but more
prosecutions you won't get the
convictions
without the prosecutions in the first
place and i really think it's time that
the government look closely at having
a women's justice strategy so that we
can see
victims supported from the start to the
end of the process
yeah as you say there are some clear
issues with the process not enough women
coming forward
not enough referring to the cps and then
if you look at the last three years rape
conviction is more than halving
in england and wales i mean one of the
most controversial suggestions from lady
dorian is the fact that actually some of
these trials
should be heard not by juries who may be
vulnerable to
rape myths for example but by trained
judges
i mean is that the kind of road that we
need to go down if we're going to get
serious about getting convictions
well we have a long history and
principle
of crimes being tried by a jury of your
peers in this country
and i think that that is important but i
also think it's right that we have a
full and frank conversation about how we
can do things better how perhaps we can
do things quicker i thought
one of the most important points that
lady dorian made was about
victims having to relive their trauma
potentially
many times and over a long period and i
think that we need to find a way that
the whole process can be speeded up so
that victims see cases coming
to court much more quickly and then have
the opportunity
to move on with the rest of their lives
it does feel doesn't it that one of the
positive
things after a really grueling couple of
weeks for so many women has been
that we are starting to have a more full
and frank conversation about the kind of
harassment and the kind of assault as
well that some people face
and so many women do see as a fabric of
their lives you
recently gave an interview where you
said a labour mp tried to grape you
i mean talk about your own experience if
you want to obviously don't feel that
you have to
but how much of an issue do you think
this is for
for all women the kind of things that
we've been hearing
it's too common in every walk of life in
every
um and this will be shocking for people
here in every school playground
in every university in every workplace
this is going on far too
often and when you read the statistics
about the number of young women
that have been subject to sexual assault
or harassment
they're horrific and that's why i'm very
happy to co-sign amendments with people
like harriet harman
to make sexual harassment in a public
place uh outlawed
i think that that's really important we
have to change the culture
and that's why my committee has uh in
this last week
launched an inquiry into
the cultures that are underpinning male
violence against women i think it's
crucial
that we don't just um
don't just pontificate on this we need
some practical solutions and we need
them quickly whether that be through
the court system whether that's through
education whether we have a
candid conversation about pornography
the ease of access to it for young
people
and what that's doing to give them a
completely skewed
impression of what adult sexual
relationships are like
talking about changing the culture the
sunday mirror has a story this morning
about the culture within the police
and former police officers criticizing
sexism and
misogyny sir peter fahey who's the
former chief constable of greater
manchester police said that if a member
of his family was attacked
he would probably advise him not to
report it he also said
there's no way his daughter would join
the police force
is there a problem of sexism in the
police
well i think that's a matter for the
police themselves to
investigate and look at but reports like
that advising your children not to join
the police
not wanting to report crimes i think we
have a really important
job to do here empowering women who are
victims of crime
to go to the police to know that they
will be believed that they will have
their cases listened to sympathetically
i know here in hampshire police there
are more than 100 officers
working on this sort of crime um and
it's treated
with great sensitivity and care um but
that's led by a female chief constable
who is absolutely committed to doing
that
i think it's absolutely vital that we
have to find
better ways to give women confidence and
when you look at the the statistics
around sexual violence the statistics
around sexual harassment
unfortunately we're letting far too many
women down
okay thank you so much for coming on the
program this morning and caroline next
there thank you
now it's going to be a big week in
scotland which could determine the fate
of the first minister nicholas sturgeon
there are not one but
two reports due into the way in which
the scottish government
mishandled complaints of sexual
misconduct against alex salmond
and whether nicola sturgeon personally
broke the ministerial code by misleading
the scottish parliament
about what she knew and when
we're joined now by the scottish health
secretary gene freeman
if nicolas sturgeon is found to have
broken the ministerial code
should she resign well we don't have
either of those two confirmed reports
yet so
we're getting a bit of ahead of
ourselves the most important one
is actually the independent inquiry into
whether the first minister
breached the ministerial court that she
referred herself to
in january 2019 we expect that report
uh this week and that is the one where
uh
uh james hamilton the qc uh is has
looked at all of these matters and he
will
produce his conclusions that's that's
the one that is genuinely independent
and objective
and we will see what that report says
and then the first minister will
take the necessary decisions after that
a poll for sky news found that 51
of people thought that nicola sturgeon
should resign if she broke the
ministerial code just 35
said she should stay in her job and she
of course has spoken about the
importance of it too
you know when she launched the minister
of code in 2018 she said i'll lead by
example
in following the letter and spirit of
the code surely
if she is found to have broken the code
she needs to go doesn't she
well the first minister has led by
example
uh throughout and i think the public
particularly the public in scotland have
seen
how open and frank her leadership is
uh particularly over the last year when
we've been dealing with the pandemic
the the committee report is not yet
concluded what we have
is unattributable briefings and leaks
from that committee which is actually as
it happens against the msp code
of conduct so the the situation here
is important it's serious what's most
serious actually
is that the scottish government made
serious mistakes
in handling and implementing the policy
on harassment and the people who have
suffered most
in that are the women who brought those
complaints that's what the committee
was supposed to be looking at but even
before
the first minister appeared in front of
that committee and for eight hours
answered their questions
even before that the scottish
conservatives were calling for her
resignation
so i think we can dismiss some of that
at least as a bit of partisan politics
40 odd days out from a scottish election
and focus our attention
on what the genuine the independent
report
from mr hamilton qc says when we receive
that i hope this week
not uh long to wait for that i'm keen to
talk to you about covid as well because
of course
we've had these issues of vaccine
supplies and delayed shipment from india
nicola sturgeon saying this week
scotland is going to have half a million
fewer doses over the next month than
anticipated what does that mean for the
vaccine rollout in scotland
well what it means is that there is a
lot of
we model every single day the
anticipated supply against the scheduled
appointments
we think having remodeled on the basis
that
those 500 doses will not come when we
expected them to come
we do expect them to come later but they
won't come when we thought
we still believe that we're able to meet
our commitment which was
that we will uh offer a vaccination
appointment to everyone
in those jcbi priority groups one to
nine so that's everyone
over 50 and those people with underlying
health conditions are clinically
extremely vulnerable
and unpaid carers and we believe we're
still on track to do that
and to have vaccinated all adults over
18 in scotland by the end of july and
we're
over 2 million vaccinated now
so we keep looking at it every day what
we have to be sure to do though
is make sure that not only can we
deliver first roses
but that we are delivering the second
dose which is very important
within the 12-week window so that's the
work that's underway and
as of today we still are confident that
we
can make that mid-april commitment and
we'll keep on looking at
it every day i look at it every day and
my officials work on it
constantly um of course primary schools
in scotland have been reopened for some
time now the youngest pupils going back
on the 22nd of february
you must have some data coming in by now
and what does it
show when it comes to rising cases so
there's been
a small uptick in cases but it is
it is small and we keep an eye on that
all the time the
case positivity number which is also one
of as you know one of the
important uh bits of information that
you look at all the time
it remains relatively low but uh
we just monitor this all the time and we
said in all the steps that we've uh set
out the first minutes to set out on
tuesday just gone
about how we intend to ease restrictions
second of april fifth of april end of
april
uh all of that of course is dependent on
continuing to keep
virus numbers low and bring it down case
numbers down even from where it is just
now
on the one hand and be able to deliver
the vaccination
program on the other so we remain
cautiously optimistic that we are still
on track
but i think everybody knows all your
viewers will know and certainly those in
scotland know
that this is a constant exercise and
what we are
desperately trying to avoid so the
approach is cautious
is that they turn to a flood lockdown
nobody nobody wants that
uh individually for people's mental
health and well-being seeing family and
friends
but also in economic terms and
absolutely in terms
of people's health just finally um on a
quite different subject if i may and a
rangers football player this week
glenn camara said he was been racially
abused by a slavia plague prayer
now i'm not going to repeat the words
because frankly they are far too
offensive
um but for months footballers have been
taking the
knee for black lives matter if no action
is taken
in the face of racist abuse is football
just plain lip service
well of course it's up to it is up to
the football authorities the club and
the football authorities
uh both in scotland and uh as i think
internationally
but i would hope it's not enough to be
against racism you've got to actively be
anti-racist
uh in the same way as you have to be
actively anti-misogynist you know
it's not enough to say i'm not racist
you need to call it out
and deal with it so i would hope that
the proper investigation is done there
and that the proper action is taken
because really in this century we should
be well
past insulting and dismissing
and down diminishing fellow human
beings on the base of of their race
their color
their sex any disability these things
are just
ridiculous in this day and age and we
need to do something about it
okay gene freeman thank you very much
for being on the programme thank you
thank you
well that is it for this week a busy
show do check out the safe original
sunday podcast we'll record it just
after the show
and it should be available from
lunchtime coming up don't go anywhere it
is
the take with our political
correspondent rob pal going through the
best bits
of the interviews for this week see you
next sunday
[Music]
you